Hello and welcome
to the Microbiology
Detection of
Microbes lecture.
This is a really
important lecture because
it sets the stage for
a lot of both clinical
understanding of
laboratory microbiology
diagnoses and all
different types of essays,
tests, cultures,
microscopy
that's involved in that.
These are the objectives
of the session. In
a nutshell, we need
to be able to explain
the basic and general
aspects of diagnostic
microbiology and how
does that help in
understanding disease,
describe the various tests
that are often used
in the clinical micro
lab and for the purpose
of identifying the
ideological agent
and to help you as a
clinician to make the
right diagnosis. You
should be able to compare
and contrast different
types of diagnostic
microbiological assays
and when to use one,
not use the other,
and understand the
algorithm behind them.
Also determine
diagnoses of the disease
is based on the
laboratory findings here's
a lecture outline
to help you follow
through basically
initially you're going to
talk about basic
laboratory tests and
what they do and then
we'll start dividing
them by what they
are mainly microscopy
culture and chemical
testing serology and
molecular techniques
and so we'll go
through each one of
them and talk about the
rules of each and how
important they are.
These are all types
of laboratory tests
that aid the condition
and identification
of disease. One of
them, of course, is
a routine blood test
like complete blood
count and, for
example, there's a high
white blood cell
count that suggests
that there's an
infection. All these help
your analysis, etc.
Our focus is more
going to be about
microbiological
diagnostic tests,
so the staining,
what kind of
stains, what
information do we get,
and then culture type
of cultures and unique
cultures that are used
i will talk a little
bit about different
biochemical testings
like for example
lactose fermentation and
other types of sugar
we talk about testing
the antigens of microbes
in order to detect
them and also detect
also we can use detection
of antibodies which
is called serology to
indirectly measure the
presence of a pathogen.
And then we'll also
discuss molecular
techniques like nucleic
acid amplification,
polymerase chain
reaction, and gene probes.
And of course I have
notes for you talks
about like a lot of
times culture still
is the kind of the
key thing that we do,
one of the main ways,
but sometimes you
can't culture an
organism. Just no matter
how much we're trying
to build different
types of culture,
they are not cultural,
that's why you have to
rely on other approaches
to identification
of these microbes.
Let's discuss microscopy
and we will talk
about these different
microscopic techniques
in more detail, for
example, their step-by
-step process, etc. At
least let's outline them
and we'll do that in
the coming lectures.
But at least one
of the most common
microscopic and
staining procedure,
in bacteriology
at least, is
the gram stain.
Now remember that
staining is needed
to provide contrast.
You're unable to really
see pathogens which
are very small under
the microscope, even
human cells, without
staining to provide
that contrast. So
that's why we stain.
Of course before
we do that we have
to fix a specimen
and make sure it
doesn't it washed.
And simply that can be
done by simply
heating the specimen.
But the gram stain
basically differentiates
most bacteria into
either the gram positive
which is purple in
color based on the
crystal violet dye
versus the gram negative
which is red or pink
that's based on the
saffron in there which
is a counter stain.
Again most common
bacteriological stain
typically one of the
first ones people do in
a lab to kind of
separate the organisms.
Not all microbes,
not all bacteria fall
under this, especially
if they don't have
a cell wall, because
the staining property
is based on the cell
wall. And so things
like microplasma,
which we'll discuss
later, don't have
walls, and hence they
wouldn't be gram-positive
nor gram-negative,
okay?
So again, very
important stain.
Another extremely
important stain is a
fluorochrome type of
stain, or fluorescent
type of stain,
called the oramine
-rhodamine stain. The
oramine-rhodamine
stain is currently
the stain that is used
clinically to
identify species like
mycobacteria, which
causes tuberculosis,
especially mycobacterium
tuberculosis.
There are multiple
species of
mycobacteria, so the
mycobacterium avium,
mycobacterium complex,
intercellular, etc.
But the otamine
-rhodamine stain is able
to identify, and you
can also identify
cryptosporidium,
which is a protozoan
commonly involved
in GI infections.
So with this stain,
these cells would
appear red, kind of
maroon colored, and
the oramine-rhodamine
stain allows the
person doing the
microscopy to scan the
slide very quickly,
looking quickly for
these red. So they
allow you to go through
a big specimen in
order to identify.
And for counter
stain for the oramine
-rhodamine, so things
are not mycobacteria
or cryptosporidium,
which is also
referred to as acid
fast, potassium
permanganate is used
as a counter stain.
This test,
the oramin-rhodamine,
has replaced
what's called the
acid fast stain or
the Zeal-Nelson
stain. So the Zeal
-Nelson stain, one of
the oldest stains,
now usually typically
now used anymore
in the clinical
setting. You do need to
know about it because
sometimes they'll
have board exam
questions still on it,
so we'll discuss it a
little bit, But just
be aware it's not
the currently one
used in the clinical
laboratory setting.
But based on that acid
fast stain, species
such as microbacteria
are referred to
as acid fast because
of that property.
We will discuss
that more.
Next one is the right
Gimsa stain, a very
important stain for
differentiation of like
protozoans, especially
in blood smears. This
will help you identify
Plasmodium, which is
the cause of the region
of malaria, Babesia,
Trichomonas,
Toxoplasmosis, even some
bacteria like Chlamydia
and Rickettsia,
and we'll discuss
what those are in
later lectures, of
course. But yeah,
the Gryde-Gimster
stains are, again,
key thing here is
it really helps
identifying with
protozoans, and we'll
look at these stains
in a little bit.
Next is the India ink
stain, extremely useful
specifically for
identification of
Cryptococcus neoformans.
Cryptococcus neoformans
is a fungi that actually
makes a capsule.
It's one of the only
fungi that makes a
capsule so it's easy
you can identify it with
that stain and I'll
show you a picture of
that. Usually that's
done on a cerebrospinal
fluid specimen and
crypto can cause
meningitis and so it's
a very serious disease
so this could help with
the identification.
Continuing with
microscopy the capsule
stain is also a
specialized stain
that helps identify
bacteria that can
actually have capsules.
Not all bacteria
have capsules. Some
do, some don't.
The majority, I
would say, don't. And
even some strains of
the same bacteria can
have a capsule, some
not. For example,
the streptococci have
capsules, but you can
also find strains of
cryptococci that don't
have capsules. And
as we talked about
earlier, the fungi
cryptococcus have capsules.
It is important to
identify if the organism
has capsules because of
the increased virulence
and pathogenicity,
meaning the ability
to cause disease and
the seriousness of the
pathogen. Another
specialized microscopy
stain is the flagellar
stain, and this helps
identify bacteria
that can move a lot.
Some bacteria
have a lot of
motility, so to
speak, and some
don't, and some
have average.
Highly motile
bacteria would be an
example, like the
genus Proteus, which is
a common that
causes urinary tract
infection, so that
could help with that.
And then the third
specialized stain here
we're talking about
is the spore stain.
The spore stain actually
identifies endospore
-forming bacteria.
So this is specially
designed for the genuses
Bacillus and Clostridia.
These are the only
two genuses of
bacteria that actually
form spores. Both of these
are gram-positive
rods or bacilli. like.
So things like
Bacillus anthracis,
Bacillus cereus, or
Plastridium
botulinum, Plastridium
perfringens would
be examples of that.
In the next few slides
I want to show you
pictures of all the
things we have discussed
to kind of come on the
horizon with this. So
one of them here is
the gram stain. We can
see on this slide both
gram positive as shown
right here on the left
side and gram positive
and here is gram
negative so of course
gram positive as you
can see right here and
these are purple so a
gram stain can tell us
if it's gram positive
purple or gram negative
like you can see right
here which is kind
of pink to red color
based on that safranin
any microscopy
microscopic stain can also
help you identify
the shape of the
organism so the ones
right here are cocci,
they're spherical,
while the ones right
here appear to me to
be small rods, okay.
And so that can also
differentiate between
your organisms. You can
also look at pattern,
and so one of the
patterns I see right
here on this left side
in the grand positives
is clumping, and also
specifically grape
-like clusters. What
I see right here in
grape-like clusters
are referred to as
staphylococci. So the term
staphylococci, staphylo
means grape, like
cocci means round, and
that's where the genus
named Staphylococcus
comes from. So it kind
of helps with that.
Staphylococci are
gram-positive cocci in
clumps. This is a gram
stain of Staphylococcus,
always a non-common
pathogen. On the other
hand, here on the
right side, I see gram
-negative rods. I don't
see a specific pattern,
they all seem to be
randomly everywhere.
This is specifically
Ischerichia coli,
which is a common enteric
gram-negative rot.
This is a slide
showing an
oramine-rhodamine stain.
A really neat one,
so on the left
side right here
is the oramine
-rhodamine, and you
can see right there
the fluorescent
cells. So, quick,
whenever you see
those, you know
that you have an
acid-fast organism.
So, this could be
mycobacteria, but it
could also be other
things, like it could
be Cryptococcus,
it could be Cardia,
and there's some
other type of bacteria
that can stay acid
-fast. So, mycobacteria
aren't the only
acid-fast organisms.
So, this tells you that
these are acid-fast
positive, but it does
not determine the
genus of the species.
That is important.
in comparison here
it is showing you
the what the acid
fast thing would look
like so the acid
fast the older one
the zeal nelson uh
the you can see here
we can see uh acid
fast positive rods
again that only tells
us they are acid fast
positive it doesn't
tell us that these are
micro bacteria or
something specific but
it definitely points
in that direction and
more laboratory tests
are needed like culture
but this would be a
great start okay now
again the The oramine
-rhodamine is pretty
quick. Both of these
things are pretty quick.
The oramine-rhodamine
is more sensitive.
It's actually faster.
It's probably more
expensive, but there's
less error rate and not
as many steps involved
and the likelihood
of causing a mistake.
It doesn't really require
a lot of expertise
to do. And that's
why I bought it. It's
been replacing the
old Zeal-Nelson stain.
Here again showing
you what the
classic Zeal
-Nelson stain would
look like for
acid-fast cells.
So this is not the Gram
stain, right? So be
careful with that. And
one of the key things
that people do is
every time they see
something blue, they
say it's Gram positive.
Well, only if it's the
Gram stain. This is
not the Gram stain.
This is the Zeal-Nelson
stain or the acid
-fast stain. So in this
case, the acid-fast
positive cells are the
pink ones right here,
while the blue ones
are acid fast negative
okay but of course
the acid fast negative
here are probably
staphylococci because
they are as you can see
in clusters and they're
cocci and staphylococci
are not acid fast
and so it makes
sense that they are
negative and here we see
rod shaped acid fast
positive likely again
micro bacteria but we
wouldn't know unless
we do any further
testing Again, remember,
the stain is not used
commonly anymore,
but there are still
some board questions
that have it, and I
can assure you of that.
So this is actually
a confirmed
stain of mycobacteria.
We can see here these
large cells. Those
are probably macrophages,
which tends to
be common whenever
you have mycobacteria.
So they will swallow.
Although the, you
know, mycrophages are
phagocytic, and by
definition, they'll
try to eat, phagocytize
the organism. So
these are actually
mycrophages that have
phagocytized the rod
-shaped mycobacteria
inside of them. So when
you do the acid fasting,
you see all this
pink mycobacteria,
tons of them inside,
thousands of them
actually, inside
the cells.
This is a right Gimsa
stain of plasmodia.
Plasmodia is the
parasite that
causes malaria, and
so you can see the
actual plasmodia
inside red blood
cells, and so that
kind of highlights
that. So it's really
helpful with that.
And this is the India
Inc. capsule stain
of cryptococcus. You
can clearly see here
is the cryptococci,
the actual fungal cell,
and the halo around
it is the capsule. So
this halo right here,
as I'm pointing out
is which seems to be
almost as large as
the cell and bigger
and that's that's the
capsule right there and
definitely highlights
that this is a
cryptococci. It can be
very definitive and
highly diagnostic
especially high value
and so quick and simple.
This is a capsular stain
of bacteria I think
we're looking at again
here cocci and so
this is probably
streptococci and so you can
see here I think there's
two of them right
there right here right
here let me use the
red color so you can
see so I'm looking at
these so I'm thinking
here there's two cocci
right there one two
so they kind of close
together they're
probably dividing that's
why the capsule is so
large same here see I
could see one right
there the cocci and
another one right here
okay and then the capsule
right about note the
capsule is so huge
compared to the actual
size of the cell and
so has a very big
advantageous protection.
We'll discuss that
more in the bacterial
physiology lecture that
talks about capsules
and how the capsules
benefit the microbe.
Of course don't benefit
the host but they
definitely benefit the
microbe. The flagellar
stain as you can see
right here highlights
the flagella very nicely
from the organism.
So these hair-like,
long hair-like
structures coming out
of this rod shaped cell
is the flagella and
sometimes the position
of the flagella can
tell us help us a little
bit identification for
example these cells
here rod shape have
flagella coming out
of everywhere so that's
referred to as you
know uh like peritricus
flagella but there's
sometimes some have
only one flagella on
one side or maybe just
two one on each side
so you can tell that
can help you also with
the identification
and confirms that the
cells, the
bacteria in this
case, are able to move.
This is the endospore
stain. The endospore
stain uses malachite
green to stain
spores. So these are
the spores. Anything
that looks green right
here in this particular
slide are the
spores. The ones that
I read are the cells,
just regular cells.
In this case they're
called vegetative cells
by definition. You can
also see like right
here this cell this
is a vegetative cell
with a spore forming
inside of it hence the
name endospore so the
spores form inside
the cell eventually
they are released into
the environment as free
spores but initially
they are formed
inside the cell as
endospores you see
several of them here that
you can identify inside
the vegetative cell
in this case the cell
would be called the
mother cell because
it's giving rise to
the spore this again
helps identification of
species such as
Clostridia and Bacillus.
Bacillus also means
rod but in this case
we're talking about
the Bacillus genus
like Bacillus anthracis,
Bacillus cereus.
So we've discussed
the role of
microscopy and different
stains to help us
in the identification
of microbes.
Next thing we're going
to talk about how
culture. Now let me
just say something,
keep in mind that for
a lot of the things
we talked about, they're
mainly for fungi,
viruses, sorry,
fungi, bacteria,
and parasites. But
viruses can also
be identified
microscopically.
But because they're
so small, you need an
electron microscope to
be able to visualize
viruses. And that's
not something commonly
done. In pathology,
though, you can look
for the effects of
virus, like inclusion
bodies and things
like that to kind of
see if there's a viral
infection and we'll
we'll discuss those also
later as you progress
in your pre-clinical
education but now
we're going to focus
on culture how we
use culture for
identification typically
this is kind of like
how it works you first
you do a stain and
you do a particular uh
identifying by the
microscope and then
decide on what next to
do as far as culture.
Now, the source of
the culture material,
the sample that comes
from the patient, you
know, one of the most
common things, of
course, is samples as
blood sample, urine,
stool, CSF, but of
course you can get
other samples like
you can get a sample
from any pus from a
boil or other type of
tissue samples may
not be as common, but
you know, aspirate
like a needle aspirate
and things like
that so so these are
examples like sputum
sample if you're
looking at you want
to check somebody with
tuberculosis skin if
they have a lesion
swab the throat and
you know like aspirate
of an abscess or even
you know synovial
fluid from the knee
if somebody has an
infection or sometimes
like reductobot
biopsied material
from a specific like
tissue and so on. So
these are all sources
of different material
that can be cultured.
As we've discussed
in the prior lecture
there's a lot of
different cultures.
We have broth and
that's for enrichment.
We have agars and
these can come in
slants or in plates.
Most commonly we use
plates and so here
we're going to focus
a little bit on
specifically agar
plates. Agar plates
are used to grow both
bacteria and fungi
for the most part.
One of the most
common type of fungal
growth plate is
Saborods dextrose agar.
You can see
it right here.
So it's a very common
type of agar for the
growth of fungi. Sometimes
called potato agar
or potato dextrose
agar or sabora's agar
or just different
terminology used for that
it's a general purpose
media that will grow
fungi and just a lot
of other things so
it's considered non
-selective it doesn't really
you know favor one
thing over the other
just it's basically
starch and fungi like
starch you know how
fungi can grow in the
fridge on breads and
something like that, so
you just give it starch
and they go fine.
Blood agar is also an
example of a
non-selective.
It's just, you
know, a good general
nutritious agar. It
grows a lot of different
bacteria, mainly
what's called non
-fastidious. If a
bacterium is fastidious,
that means it's
needy, it needs
a lot of required,
it doesn't grow
easily, it needs a
lot of nutrients, etc.
And that's the
terminology what that
means. You know, for
example, there's also
something called
chocolate agar.
Chocolate agar is pretty
much blood agar but
the when you add the
blood to the agar
you you keep the
agar hot and that
basically lyses all
the blood and releases
all the contents of
red blood cells and
the agar itself
turns like brown dark
brown like chocolate
and that's what my
name is. There's no
chocolate in it, it's
just lysed blood.
This is specific agar
that is made to help
promote the growth
especially of
Haemophilus influenzae.
Haemophilus influenzae
can cause upper
respiratory tract infection
also the third common
cause of meningitis and
so it's a fastidious
bacterium and if you
don't it will not
grow on blood agar it
has to have chocolate
agar also Neisseria
gonorrhea which causes
gonorrhea also requires
chocolate agar and
sometimes requires a
lower oxygen tension than
what we have typically
in the air so it
needs like 5% oxygens,
the typical 21%. And
then we have selective
and differential types
of eggers, and those
can help distinguish.
So let me erase, sorry,
the previous one, so we
can focus on the next.
Okay.
And so selective
differential, these type
of eggers, we've mentioned
them before, help
specifically grow a
certain type of organism
and favor one over
the other and they
can also sometimes tell
the difference between
two different so
that the selective is
favoring one let's say
favoring gram negative
over gram positive
or gram positive or
gram negative and
differential for example
telling the
difference between
a fermenter of
sugar or not
new classic example of
those is the mcconkey
agar and also eosin
methylene blue or
emb agar aeosin
-methylene blue. Both of
these acres are very
similar. They both are
selective for gram
negative enteric rods,
and so these are the
rods that live in our
intestines, hence the
term enteric. Enteric
intero always refers
to the GI tract.
And see, these guys all
belong to the family
known as the
Enterobacteriasis. It's a
really important
family because a lot of
pathogens that
causes GI illness
belong to that. So
examples, E. coli,
Salmonella, Shigella,
Klebsiella,
Pastorella,
Pseudomonas, Proteus,
Serratium, and so on.
So Maconkey and
EMB both have a lot
of bile salts in
them, which favor the
growth of these
enteric rods, gram
negative, it inhibits
gram positives.
Also they have a pH
indicator, so if the
organism is a lactose
fermenter and there's
lactose in these
media, it will make the
course fermentation,
produces acids in this
case, we're talking
acid fermentation, drops
the pH, the color
changes and you know
typically becomes
yellow. So if it's a
fermenter it will turn
yellow and that's a lactose
fermenter and if it
does not turn the
pH it means it's a non
-fermenter. It still
can grow but it does
not change the color.
Let's look into other
selected medium such
as Lewinstein-GensenAger.
Lewinstein-GensenAger
is specifically designed
to grow mycobacteria,
especially mycobacteria
tuberculosis.
So if you suspect
somebody has tuberculosis
TB you would take a
sputum sample from them
and you will send it
to the lab to grow on
Lewinstein-GensenAger.
This is the gold
standard for diagnosis
of TB and confirming it.
So no matter even if
you have an x-ray, even
if you're suspecting
it, even if you have a
nucleic acid amplification,
PCR, all that,
you still have to
do a culture and
that's the way to
confirm that the
person actually
has TB. That's
still the gold
standard till today.
That sometimes is a
board exam question too.
other agars are
buffered charcoal yeast
extract and this is
designed specifically for
legionella pneumophilia
is an organism that
causes legionnaires
disease it's basically
an upper respiratory
tract pneumonia could
be a low respiratory
tract infection another
one again there's
a lot of those by the
way i'm just giving
you the most common
ones just a few examples
we can't get into
all of them you know
at some point you'll
have to know a lot of
them but this just a
kind of an abduction.
Bordet gingu agar
is also specific
for the Bordetella
species,
especially Bordetella
pertussis, which
causes pertussis or
holding cough, okay?
So all these agars
can grow bacteria
and, you know, Saborods
grows fungi. Now,
when it comes to
viruses, because
viruses cannot grow
by themselves like
bacteria can because
they're not cellular,
you actually have
to grow them on
tissue culture. So
you need an actual
tissue cell line
to grow viruses.
We just spoke about
different kinds of
cultures and now we need
to talk about different
culture conditions
by which to grow
many bacteria. These
conditions also sometimes
help us identify
specific bacteria
based on these things.
So the key conditions
are oxygen requirements
and that's typically
for metabolism and
temperature. Let's
first talk about the
oxygen requirements.
Bacteria can live
in a variety of
oxygenated environments.
They can live
in typical oxygen,
that's like air,
21%, but they can
live in a small
oxygen environment
like microidophilic,
that's to be like
5%, or they can
live without
oxygen at all, and
those are referred
to as anaerobic.
The requirement as
far as oxygen has
to do with whether
or not they have the
enzymes that
break down oxygen
radicals, because if
they don't have the
enzymes to break
down oxygen radicals,
then basically
the organisms will
die. For example,
anaerobic bacteria
cannot deal with
oxygenated environment
because they don't
make any of the enzymes
that process
oxygen radicals.
Microatomphiles make
a little bit and so
because they make a
little bit they can live
in a small oxygen
tension but they can live
in a full oxygen
tension such as aerobic.
There's also other
bacteria called facultative
aneurobes and facultative
aneurobes tend
to be one of the
most common types of
bacteria and they can
also live in all kinds
of different environment.
In other words, they
can live with all the
way from no oxygen
to full oxygen, so
they're very well adapted.
So when growing your
cultures, you have
to be mindful of what
you're trying to grow.
For example, if
we're trying to grow
Costridia, Costridia by
definition are anaerobic
spore forming rods.
You have to have the
environment anaerobic.
If there's any air,
they will not grow.
If you're trying
to grow Neisseria,
they prefer 5%. If
you're to grow
bacillus, like bacillus
anthracis, there
are strict erupts or
pseudomonas and so
on, so be mindful of
the oxygen requirement.
And that all
has to do with
metabolism, how they can
basically break down,
basically generate ATP.
The other
factor that plays a role
here is temperature.
Temperature is
important too, so most
organisms, especially
most pathogenic bacteria,
usually like to
live around 35 to 37
degrees Celsius,
which is our blood
temperature, our
body temperature.
So they're
adapted for that,
and they live fine there.
very few can do
40 to 42 celsius
and that's pretty
much what fever
is like so very
few of them can
live at that one and
usually their rate of
growth will decrease
and fungi prefer room
temperature room temperature
to colder temperatures
that's something to
remember which is
why fungi will live
mostly are superficial
so they live in our skin
and places like that
because they really
don't like our body
temperature. Our skin is
usually cooler of course
than our inner body
temperature and this
has to do with their
enzymes and so their
proteins basically and
how what they can function
at. So ideally for
these organisms here
what's sometimes called
mesophiles they like
to 35 to 37 so so we
have to consider again
oxygen requirements
as well as temperature
when we're doing growth
of cultures beyond
microscopy and culture
environment and cultural
plates there there is
a need to also follow
up with other tests
one of them is after
that was is biochemical
assays and those tend
to be you know common
sometimes you're able
to figure out microbe
with the gram stain,
the pattern and
the shape, and
sometimes the
culture can help you.
But many times you
need to move on to or
follow up with
biochemical assays to
confirm the identification
of the microbe.
There's a variety of
biochemical assays.
There's a full book on
how many biochemical
assays are there to
test different bacteria
in a bacteriology
lab and other labs.
So we'll discuss just
key ones, because
there's really no room
or time for all of them.
One of the key ones
is the catalase
test. So catalase
is an enzyme, and
actually this is one
of the enzymes that
helps microbes deal
with oxygen. It
basically breaks down
hydrogen peroxide,
which is an oxygen
radical, to water and
oxygen. And so if the
organism has catalase,
they will bubble.
So this is
the oxygen bubbling
right here.
Okay,
and if it's negative,
basically there will
be no bubbling like
you see on the right
side of the slide
there. Simple test,
you put colonies
of the microbes on
the growth and you
just put drops of
hydrogen peroxide and
if it fizzles like
you see that it's
catalase positive,
if it doesn't it's
catalase negative.
This test mainly
is performed to
differentiate the
group staphylococci
from streptococci
and enterococci.
While a lot of
bacteria are cannulaise
positive, the staph
and the strep and the
enterococci look the
same. They're both gram
positive, they're both
cocci, and so shape and
gram reaction is the
same. Now they do differ
a little bit in
pattern, staphylococci
are more grape-like
clusters while these guys
are in chains but that
that in myself you
cannot rely on the pattern
simply to distinguish
you need a confirmation
test just like
the catalase test so
if they're positive
they're staph if
they're negative they're
shrub or intro okay so
let's say your bacteria
turns out to be staph
catalase positive and
gram positive cocci
so that's probably
staph, but now you want
to distinguish between
staph oeus and the
other less pathogenic
type of staph, for
example, epidermidis and
saprophyticus, which
also sometimes comes up
in the same exact
sample, because all of
these organisms are
actually part of our
normal flora, so as
epidermidis found in our
skin and everywhere,
so is saprophyticus, so
they're usually isolated
together, and to
tell whether or not
you have oeus versus
epidermidis and
saprophyticus you use what's
called the coagulase
test the coagulase test
actually uses plasma
from blood and staph
has the ability has an
enzyme called coagulase
which will make the
plasma clot as you
can see right here while
the epidermidis and
saprophytus do not
have it and the plasma
will stay liquid so
this is easy and quick
way to distinguish
between those and the
species of the staff,
of the different staff.
Another biochemical
assay which can
be tested on blood
agar is hemolysis
and we've talked
about that before.
Hemolysis basically
is the ability
of bacteria to
hydrolyze blood
and so some of
them can completely
hemolyzed blood when
those are referred to
as beta hemolytic organisms
and so the colonies
usually appear clear
there's a clear zone
of hemolysis on the
blood agar wherever the
bacteria is going and
examples of that would
be both group A and
group B streptococci.
Also most strains
of S. aureus are
also beta hemolytic
some strains of
clostridium and
about half of the
strains of E. coli
are also hemolytic.
Hemolysis is of
course, it is
done by the
enzyme hemolysin,
and so the microbe has
to have that enzyme.
Now some bacteria can
only partially break down
blood, so what these
organisms will do
is they'll break the
cell, the red blood
cell, but then they
can't break the
hemoglobin all the
way so they break it
partially and they
end up with that
greenish or greenish
brown color of the
bloods which indicates
partial hemolysis.
An example of these
are some of the
streptococci like
strep pneumo or
streptococcus pneumoniae
which is one of
the main cause
evasions of pneumonia.
This one's all part
of what's referred
to the alpha hemolytic
streptococci, or
sometimes called
viridans streptococci.
Sorry,
how about that?
The viridans streptococci.
So one of the
ways to differentiate
the streptococci,
which is a large group
by the way, is by a
hemolytic reaction.
And if there's no
hemolysis whatsoever,
your organism cannot
grow, they basically
keep the blood exactly
the same, that is
called gamma hemolysis.
An example of
that are the staph
seprophyticus and staph
epidermidis, and the
interococci, like
interococcus faecalis, a
common cause of urinary
tract infections.
So as you can see
here, hemolysis through
my growth on blood
agar can tell us and
distinguish between
different bacteria.
The next few slides
are going to show
you different
hemolytic reactions. So
here is the beta
hemolysis and this is
evident by the clearing
of anywhere there's
bacterial growth
and there's colonies
there's clear the
blood is completely
digested if you
hold this up to the
light you can see
right through it this
is alpha hemolysis
as you can see this
is streptococci
or alpha hemolytic
streptococci you can
see this greenish
color brown here of
the organism okay
showing partial
hemolysis.
There's also another
test going on
here called the
optogen test, and
we'll discuss that
in a little bit.
We just saw the optogen
test on the slide
before, and what that
is, it's basically
a selective inhibitor
of streptococcus
pneumoniae, so it
helps distinguishes
the alpha hemolytic
streptococci-like
as pneumoniae, which is
susceptible to optogen,
from the other strep,
the coccyne, which
are resistant. And so
if you can see here,
there's a halo next to
the optogen disc around
it, and so there's no
growth of the organism
right there. See
the halo? It cannot
grow, so they are
susceptible. While this type
of strep, strep midas,
is resistant to optogen,
it can grow all the
way to the disc, and
it doesn't care whether
that inhibitor is
there or So this is
kind of a quick, you can
grow the ****** of blood
agar, look for alpha
haemosis, and also for
optician sensitivity,
and you can knock
both at the same time.
Another dys-sensitivity
test referred to
as the A dys-sensitivity,
and that basically
refers to the
antibiotic basitrecin.
So basitrecin
actually can inhibit
streptococcus pneumoniae,
which is part of
that group B streptococci,
which are beta
-hemolytic, but all the
other beta-hemolytic
streptococci are
resistant to the A-disc
basytracin, so it helps
distinguish strep pneumo
from other beta
-hemolytic streptococci.
You can see right here,
here's the big halo
of sensitivity around
the basytracin disc,
while this is growing
all the way. So this
would be right there
here is strep pyogenes.
Continuing with the
biochemical tests, we saw
before McConkie agar
and EMB which tests
for lactose fermentation.
So fermentation is
one of the common
biochemical tests or any
kind of sugar fermentation
that is done in the
bacteriology lab and
there's many sugars
can be done could be
lactose sucrose maltose
glucose you can run a
battery of sugars actually
run a battery of 24
different sugars and
see whether or not the
organism can ferment
the sugar and produce
an acid so when it does
it produces an acid
it will change the
color there'll be a pH
indicator usually phenol
red and it will turn
to yellow and so here
Here, one easy
way or one good
way to use lactose
fermentation
specifically is
to distinguish
E. coli and
Klebsiella, which are
both lactose
fermenters, from other
gram-negative
entetic rods like
Salmonella,
Shigella, and so on.
So if you remember,
all of those are
part of the
Enterobacteriaceae, these
are all the gram
-negative rods that
live in our intestines
and our guts.
Here's a quick
slide showing
lactose fermentation
on maconkyager.
On the top here there
is the un-inoculated
plate and down here
this is what it looks
like the colonies
they look like if they
are lactose fermenters.
They will turn the
you'll turn
the phenol red,
very kind of pinkish
red, very nice
hue, and if they're
lactose non-fermenters,
basically negative,
they will just
keep the agar pretty
much the same. It
doesn't really change
its color much.
There's a sugar
fermentation test called
sorbitol, a sugar
called sorbitol, and the
The key thing about
surroglital is you can
actually add it into
McConkie, and usually
it's used to identify
a specific strain
of E. coli, referred
to as E. coli 0157.
This usually refers
to the capsule that
it has. So this is
also known as the
intrahemorrhagic E.
coli, or sometimes called
shikatoxin-producing
E. coli. The issue
with this E. coli is
usually it contaminates
beef, and when it
does, people eat like
say hamburgers
undercooked meat or
undercooked hamburgers
and it's a very serious
E. coli which can
cause life-threatening
kidney failure
especially in young
children it cannot
this strain of E. coli
cannot ferment sorbitol
where all the other
strains of E. coli
that are not the
enterohemorrhagic will
ferment so this allows
us to distinguish
this very virulent
pathogen from other
strains of E. coli.
Another biochemical test
is called the
oxidase test.
The oxidase test
basically is from
the name, the oxidase
enzyme is one of
the enzyme, the
electron transport
chain. This typically
suggests an aerobic
organ zone, so a
classic example
would be Pseudomonas.
Pseudomonas is
oxidase positive.
These are also other
examples of bacteria
that are oxidase
positive like
Campylobacter, Helicobacter,
Vibrio, and some
strains of Neisseria
and Pastorella.
This is the oxidase
positive when the
reagent is added and
you see a purple
color that usually
signifies that it's
oxidase positive.
Now so far we've
completed microscopy,
culturing, and biochemical
testing. We're going
to move on to the
molecular, oh sorry,
before the micro
techniques we're going to
move on to antigen
detection and then we'll
talk about serology
after this so antigen
detection is actually
looking for the the
antigens using antibodies
so using the neurologic
systems designed
to detect microbial
antigens the advantage
of these are these are
very rapid tests
can take minutes the
controls are already
built in so it makes it
very simple for any
person to conduct this
experiment unlike
culturing microscopy and
biochemical testing which
require a specialized
lab, you can conduct
those in a clinic
right away. That's
the advantage of them.
You can test for antigens
using many different
assays. One of
them is the ELISA
test and that stands for
enzyme-linked
immunosorbid assay.
Usually an antibody
is put on a piece of
like a tray and then
if the antigen is there
it will attached to
it, you wash, and
then you have a way
of detecting that by
color change, a simple
color change. Another
one is the latex
agglutination test that
also can work, and
I'll show you pictures
of all of that so you
can see it better.
This slide shows the
latex agglutination
test which detects
antigen, so the antibodies
are fixed to the
latex bead as you
can see right here,
the antibodies are
these y-shaped
molecules and the round
structure is the latex
bead, And then when the
antigen, the specific
antigen binds to
the antibody, it can
actually cross-link
the different beads
together and cause them
to clump. And so
that's what that is.
Hence the word
agglutination or clumping.
Typically this
is used to, this
is the test, the
test for this
streptococcal pharyngitis.
We're sometimes
told the rapid strep
test. If somebody has
strep throat, they go
to clinic, they swap
them, and they check
for it. That's what
they're doing. They're
doing latest eclatination.
They can also test
for the cryptococcal
antigen, and so this
helps sometimes with
identification of
cryptococci, which is a fungi,
especially with like
cases of meningitis,
so you can provide a
rapid test that way.
This slide shows
the ELISA test, the
enzyme-linked enzyme
-linked immunosorbent
assay. So typically
you've got the antibody
and then you add
the antigen to it
another antibody to when
the antibody is
labeled with an enzyme.
And so that's
hence the name
enzyme-linked and
then immunosorbent
because of that binding.
And so then you add
the, of course there's
always washing between
all these steps,
so in a sense if
there's no binding and
there's no detection,
it's not the specific
one, it gets washed
off at the end you add
the signal usually
a substrate for the
specific antibody and
if the antibody is
attached you'll see
color change and the
color is typically
proportional to the quantity
of the antigen so
you can actually
determine the concentration
not not if it's
just present or not
how much so that's very
useful ELISA is a
very common technique
used for identification
for example of
autoantibodies that are
found in, let's say,
lupus, the disease,
the autoimmune disease
lupus. So you can
detect like anti-double
-strand DNA, antinuclear
antibodies. You can
also detect if the person
has hepatitis A, B,
and C. The HIV test
is also an ELISA test.
The PSA, which is
the prostate antigen
that people use
to kind of like
monitor if somebody
has prostate cancer.
The ELISA test also
tests for luteinizing
hormone, follicle
stimulating hormone, and
to check to different
fertility, and also
for human codiotropin
H which is the
pregnancy test. So also
the pregnancy test is
an ELISA. So again
ELISA is a very common
technique that has been
used for many, many
different things
throughout. Very useful.
So we've talked about
entry detection,
now we're going to
talk about serology. If
you look at the term
serology, sero means
serum. So it's
basically detecting
antibodies in serum, and
serum is part of blood.
It's after plasma
becomes coagulated,
clumps, whatever the
liquid on top that's
called serum and so
serology traditionally is
referred to as detecting
antibodies in blood
or serum and both
works fine and the same
type of tests that we
use for engine detection
we can use for
detecting antibodies and
so ELISA is one of
them but there's also
like you know acolytination
there's direct
immunofluorescence where
you have an antibody
with a fluorescent tag
which helps you fluoresce
there's complement
fixation fixing
complement and you can
see how that can be a
signaled western blot
which detects proteins.
All those can help
in detection of
antibodies. Antibodies
of course are proteins.
We use serology for
detecting a lot of
fungal infection, also
for surveillance of
fungal infection. For
example, to see how
much of a population
have histoplasmosis,
you check if they have
antibodies for it.
Cocciduidomycosis,
blastomycosis, even
sporoticiosis and
other diseases by
the way. You could
check if somebody
has let's say
antibody titers for
measles if you give
them a vaccine and
you want to see if
it worked or not.
You also use serology
for detection of
blood. So right here
this is the blood test.
This person that has
coagulated with NTA
and did not coagulate
with NTB and coagulated
with NTDs this is
a person that's A
positive this is the
RH antigen right here
and this is the the
A and you can see
the eclutination
reaction here there's no
clumping which means
they don't have blood
type B A positive
the COVID test the
antigen COVID test
that's usually people
use all the time the
little quick kit one
that's actually a
serological test what
you're testing for
is whether or not you
have the antibody for
the SARS-CoV virus.
So, so far we
have discussed
microscopy, we've
discussed culture,
developed
biochemical testing,
antigen antibody
detection. Now we're going
to move on to the
last which is the
molecular techniques and
so here we're talking
about detection of
small macromolecules
such as DNA, RNA,
and protein. So this
is referred to as
molecular techniques.
These are rapid,
very quick, minutes,
highly specific. Some
of them can detect
one copy of DNA
and very sensitive.
And so they're
powerful techniques, of
course, and they become
a lot more common
now in the last,
I would say, 15-20
years. And so
they're also a great
alternative. A lot of these
are great alternatives
to when can't
culture a microbe.
So again examples
would be those as
hybridization probes.
So for example you
have a probe
specifically that binds
a certain type of
DNA so you can detect
specific DNA to
certain bacteria like
bacteria like Azorius
or hydrocoxide
or you can detect
fungi like Candida.
Usually the probes
are attached to a
fluorescent or the
probes themselves are
attached to a fluorescent
tag and then you
watch for the
hybridization if it does
and they fluoresce
that means it's there
and the technique
used is called FISH
which stands for
fluorescent in situ
hybridization again
means in the actual
culture hybridization
another very common
I'm sure now you've
heard of it is
PCR because we've
developed a PCR assay
for COVID and so
this these are all
under what's called
nucleic acid
amplification tests.
Some of them like
PCR which makes
some of them are
non-PCR based.
So of course COVID
-19 tests the PCR
test which also
quantitates the
level of the virus
is done by PCR.
Influenza test is
also done by PCR.
Clostridioides
difficile, or sometimes
people call it CPIF
for short, if you
heard that microbe
before, that's also
detected by a nucleic
acid amplification
test that's non-PCR.
There's a lot of non
-PCR based ones like
loop amplification
techniques and so
forth. We don't have
to get into the
detail of all these
specific techniques,
just be aware of them.
The next few slides
have an actual
practice clinical
case for you
that I would like to
try to solve and it can
help you kind of with
all this information
and there's several
questions on this subject
that can also help
you just for practice.
And this here in this
example what your
board style exam item
would look like and so
here we have a 28
year old female So all
board style questions
have similar things.
First it starts with
the age and typically
there would be a ***
or if not we just say
patient or if there's
no *** assigned we say
no *** assigned and
also shows always in
the question should have
where does the patient
presents for example
are they going to
their family physician
are they going to a
clinic are they going
to the emergency
department and so the
location where they present
is important and
then what are they
presenting with. this
case they're presenting
with a temperature of
101.5 Fahrenheit. They
have also frequent
and painful urination
and it's been three
days so the duration of
this problem and also
has a low lower flank
pain. It also may
have laboratory tests
for example here it
says culturing of urine
on McConkie is shown
below so here is showing
you the McConkie and
so you should be able
to look at McConkie
and figure out from
what we talked about
today what's the purpose
of McConkie, what kind
of organism it grows,
and this is of course
a differential and
selective medium, so
it should give you two
different types of
information that can help
you narrow down what
the correct answer is.
I trust you'd be
able to do it.
And here is a summary
of the concept
that we discussed.
Summary of
concepts which are
important more so
than just the
summer in general.
But I want to read it
to you because it's
basically full sentences
that you can read.
Here's a summary
outline of what we
discussed today. You
know we talked mainly
about basic laboratory
tests especially
started out microscopy
and different stains
and then we talked
about culture and
different cultural
plates. Then we moved on
and talked about
different biochemical
testing, sugars etc.
catalase, coagulase. We
also talked about
antigen detection using
like ELISA, latex
detection. We also
talked about serology
and different kinds of
molecular techniques
like FISH and PCR.
As always, I
always appreciate
your constructive
feedback
about the lectures.
Thank you.